hey those are nice looking booms the
whole reason it's being filmed is mostly
just for the actors to like understand
situational awareness this is an age-old
trick i know right this is like one of
the oldest tricks in the book dude
imagine looking like that that's going
to be you in 10 years sam
sick
good morning and merry christmas welcome
back to another episode of visual
effects artists react that's right we've
got a whole christmas special for you
today i am very very excited to be back
with the boys on the couch talking about
christmas movies clint what does
christmas mean to you how about this how
about this crispness i'll give you my
answer at the end of the episode
stay tuned when i think of crispness i
think of a dry brittle
that satisfying crunch
it's the crunch that only crispness can
give you
it's the time to get together with
family thanksgiving but way better
thanksgiving with more lights dude it's
like fourth of july but cold it's like
the fourth of july for thanksgiving it's
like easter but with a big man it's like
valentine's day for everyone yeah
actually you don't need a date to have
fun on christmas yeah
just date your presents yeah santa
all right let's take a look at this shot
from the santa claus
shaving no big deal wait ready for it
it's pretty clear at the very least that
there's a morph happening i imagine this
is mostly coming together through
compositing notice how parts of his face
start morphing and the other parts of
his face follow suit yeah so like you
have the hair kind of growing in first
and then like his actual eyes and skin
and lips eventually transform in at the
last minute but the hair goes first to
kind of like make that transition more
seamless to pull off a shot like this
you have to keep incredibly careful
track of the orientation of his head to
be one specific direction and then match
that once they got his makeup with the
beard on dude imagine looking like that
that's gonna be you in 10 years sam
sick
so it's like all right that's a simple
morph right but or is it first let's
enhance let's enhance enhance it's on
the green screen is it two people oh i
see what you're seeing there is some
matting going on morphing is easier on a
green screen right when you don't have a
background no no no the foreground
element
whoa wait you're right here's my pitch
what do you think sam if you're going to
do a morph i would imagine you're going
to want to isolate your subject so that
way your morph isn't like morphing the
background you know you're not
rotoscoping your background you want a
clean element however you're filming on
the mirror we see that line that is in
front of his arm there i think they're
just setting up a blue screen in the
background it's actually his real
reflection it's just the entire mirror
is blue except for the line oh so the
background's comped in like tracked in
you think yeah yeah i think you're right
i think it's a big blue screen to
isolate him from the background yeah you
can see the flickering in his hair on
the bottom right how did they get the
background tracked in then like i know
how you could i'm just saying how would
they have would it have been like an
actual camera tracking thing or was
there a motion control system i would
never use a motion i would just 2d scale
that bs 1997
well they can they're morphing they can
clearly take an image and slide it
around a little bit or they probably
just got a clean plate there but for the
sake of this morph shot they put a blue
screen there so that they could replace
him and put them in there specifically
where they needed because notice how the
camera actually stops moving right
before the morph happens they land and
they lock anyways uh this movie's cool
kind of
okay i mean cool
yeah i don't know good story right merry
christmas to all
and to all a good night
when i wake up i'm getting a cat scan i
got a little clip i really wanted to do
polar express you guys already did it
and so i decided hey why not continue
the fun with the follow-up to polar
express the only way robert zamax could
ever get another motion capture movie
made is by making christmas carol
yes
great dead
there's a door nail the distance between
the tip of the dude's nose and his chin
is like that
orange and like shoved it at his face it
was like hook
you get stuck there
dude why do his fingers look like
voldemort's wand
you know what's true
back away product everything looks so
like matte yeah the skin's not quite as
like specularly reflective i personally
think this is better than the polar
express i think they made some huge
improvements granted that's five years
later the lighting is way better there's
more like global illumination better
shadows better shading and the skin
textures are better too you're actually
getting the wrinkles on their faces and
polar express they were just smooth the
polar express was really stylized
because they're trying to find the best
way to mimic the illustration style from
the book whereas this they're not
beholden to that style they're just like
hey we're just trying to make a nice
looking cg image gotcha sure yeah
it's cool that they've actually got like
jim carrey's sort of i don't even know
what you call it doesn't look like jim
carrey wait but it feels like jim carrey
that's jim carrey yeah wow all the
performances are being driven with human
actors they basically filmed this movie
with real cameras and people in motion
capture suits so that there's always a
camera on set so there is a version of
this movie where there's no graphics and
it's just the actors on the mocap stage
and this is shot for shot line for line
perfectly lined up with the movie with
the music and everything stop
back away product
see here's the scene we just watched
it's totally him put this on at the
holidays you know you know this is also
really great from a filmmaking
perspective because zemeckis can now
actually edit the film and actually get
like a cut of it put together from the
real performances while the effects are
happening in the background he doesn't
have to wait for all that stuff to be
rendered out and processed yeah it's
like i don't even know how much they
actually use that footage though to be
honest the whole reason it's being
filmed is mostly just for the actors to
like understand situational awareness
for the time like a lot of these actors
it's like this is mocap it's still new
it goes from like completely pretend
total imagination to okay there's the
camera there i know where to look or i
know how to hold my body it's not just
this void also the fact that they're
using real cameras grounds everything in
reality you're not having these giant
sweeping cameras that are impossible to
do it's pretty accurate and realistic
mocap technology has it like really
progressed much more than this honestly
no you look at like the face cap systems
and the body tracking systems they're
all kind of running on similar
technology it's really just like how
it's being processed and handled later
that's changed well like even like you
see like the little dots on his suit
that was the classic way to do mocap for
the longest time because you'd have all
these cameras that could all see those
individual dots and you're able to
extract mocap information from it these
days we have little suits that have like
accelerometers and gyros in them and so
we're able to figure it out without
having to have the dots and cameras
question though if you had the choice
would you go for the dots because it's
the more tried and true method of i
would go for the dots because everything
is explicit in world space the suits
with the sensors inside of them it's all
kind of relative it's having to make a
lot of assumptions based on like your
feet are glued to the ground and that's
how it's able to know where you're going
i mean the inertial sensors are really
great for when we go out to a shooting
range well they're just so convenient
and it's just like you can slap the
motion capture suit on without being in
a sound stage and still get great data
it's just a different tool yeah it's a
different tool okay people tomorrow
morning 10 a.m santa's coming in
oh my god will ferrell is hit or miss
for me but he just 100 in this movie
well farrell is funniest when he does go
full 100 like he's acting like an elf so
hard so we're gonna do something a
little different first i want us to take
a look at the behind the scenes and see
how they film the scene that we're about
to watch i do one with your arm straight
down and we'll put your arm in digitally
and just do everything else with your
body but don't actually throw okay
okay
okay
see how he's doing it though
he's trying not to laugh
i love this because this is exactly the
sort of style of doing a shot that we
would do you know we've actually done
something like this back in the day
remember the terraria video we did
yeah terraria yeah yeah same thing same
sort of thing where it's like all right
now don't do it and we'll just add in
your arm later so let's actually take a
look at what the final scene looks like
with the snowball fight let's go
[Music]
now we're getting a little bit of that
warbly arm
they actually shot this in central park
in new york city but then they re-shot
the scene where he was throwing the ball
so right there they shot that in
vancouver wow that's a long ways away
that's a
a really good arm i guess what i'm
getting at is they did it two different
ways they did one plate where he's
actually thrown the snowballs and then
they did another plate where he pretends
to throw him without actually moving his
arm so they can comp in a digital arm
but they have the footage of him
actually throwing that they can use but
then i actually was watching i was like
that just looks like sped up footage it
does all the motion blur is having to be
added after the fact because motion blur
is very hard to make optically correct
you can actually see his arm like
multiple times as he's going through
this is actually an animation technique
yeah imply fast motion you get like
those sort of like not speed lines but
and they're having to manually add
previous frames and tweak the opacity of
those frames yeah they're like get that
look hey can we look at a cool force
perspective shot at least oh yes so
alpha's probably most famously known for
their forced perspective
segway that a little bit
better
come on
skip
the whole idea of forced perspective
isn't really a visual effects thing it's
more of a filmmaking magic trick thing
and they did that a lot in this movie
because the age old trick
darby o'gilly figured this out 70 years
ago i know right this is like one of the
oldest tricks in the book best way to
spread christmas cheer is singing loud
for all to hear the idea of forced
perspective is to make someone look big
you got to be closer to the camera and
then they line everything up so that
from the camera's perspective doesn't
look like he's any closer to the camera
he just looks bigger and then also
obviously you want to film this with
very very deep focus so you want to stop
down so that way the children aren't out
of focus otherwise it'd feel like a
miniature exactly i still don't
understand how they're blending that
seam i see it you see this i totally see
it that little bag of lunch is actually
hiding the vertical seam and then the
horizontal seam is the wood plank going
directly behind his chair there and this
works because it's a nodal pan yes
exactly so the camera is not moving
through space it's just kind of rotating
around a hinge the real challenge is
basically just making sure your light
levels are really consistent on the
floor there are more visual effects in
this movie but i feel like those are the
ones that were most interesting to me
yeah those are the fun ones man i i'm
very sad because i'm not going to get
anything for christmas this year so i'm
requesting that you subscribe that's the
only thing i want for christmas awesome
subscription i'll subscribe right now
you're not subscribed click i'll
unsubscribe and resubscribe oh that's
not
better but okay
[Music]
oh my god okay is it time for popcorn
guy what is popcorn so i asked for
suggestions and tom ska from london
actually posted this a while ago but i
hadn't seen this just watch if anything
stands out to you let's get out of here
daddy smell like barf
anything stand out
wait no oh wait i i remember this you're
right there is a hilarious visual effect
fun
dc clint is he patching holes the guy
holding the popcorn isn't in the movie
but i forgot why they put him there it
was legit some green screen dude thrown
into this 90s movie to cover up
continuity hold on something is back
there that they don't want us to see
there's something they're hiding from us
they are hiding something you're right
who is that so it's his kid him that kid
right there ah and you can kind of see
him
you see his hat and the pants captain
disillusion actually did a video
breaking this down and he found the
original footage without the world guy
in it how do you get the original
footage how deep do you have to go i
don't know man captain d goes deep
captain deep literally the shot before
the kid gets escorted out of the shot
and then in the next scene he's right
there in the shot again so they went out
of their way to rotoscope out anakin
skywalker here and put the green screen
popcorn guy here in the shot to cover
him up genius you can tell because
there's a bit of a black matting line
around his hat and shoulders and he
almost seems a little washed out just a
little bit like the contrast is not
quite there it's not quite matched i
think the fact that there's just no
sunlight because people are getting hit
with sun yes and he's got enough they
should have shot that outside instead it
looks like they shot it in a studio
where you can't replicate that sunlight
this is the funniest type of shot you
can ever do like a random green screen
person in your movie it's the classiest
thing that was awesome
yeah thanks tom scott
so clint do you want to set up the most
christmasy of all christmas movies yeah
first let me put my head back on oh yeah
oh that means we're getting serious
we're getting serious yeah let's get
those neurons closer together
just a little tightening down this
information here
not my favorite christmas movie of all
time but
no doubt a christmas movie we're talking
about die hard
die hard
yeah wait so why is this a christmas
movie clint look at the freaking
christmas tree in the background
done done yeah that that's all the
explanation you need all right so he
strapped some c4 to this chair he chucks
it is this max payne dude chuck's down
in this elevator
whoa hey those are nice looking
booms blow out here it comes
that's cool let's talk about this
elevator first yeah what's up with this
elephant what's going on with the
elevator let's take a look it was
enhanced how do you think they're doing
that shot right there i think it's just
it's a miniature i'd say that's like in
real life that's probably about like 15
feet long how about the perspective
though how does it look like it goes on
for so long oh
it's this is the same thing from the
dune thing where they're actually
warping the model to actually get more
narrow at the end of it to kind of
create the illusion of a vanishing point
and so the lines actually kind of
converge exactly so sam they built a
23-foot miniature and it starts out as a
normal like room size you know elevator
shaft and then it tapers down to a few
feet at the bottom after those 23 feet
since it's a miniature when they set off
that explosion it's gonna look way too
fast they're not gonna get the right
speed of the explosion so they have to
shoot it in slow-mo they have to shoot
it in slow-mo but as it gets closer to
camera it appears too fast so they
actually have to ramp the whole thing so
they're filming at 100 frames per second
and as soon as the explosion goes off
the dp literally turned off the camera
so it wound down
and they just they just winged it ah
and oh wow it actually happened to work
out perfectly that's baller that's
awesome that was real time first take
first try timer mapping exactly exactly
things would get really dim up towards
the top because the fire would kind of
go out towards the top so what they had
to do is they did three takes of this
explosion and they come to them together
to get the brightness that they needed
towards the top of that explosion that's
the only way you can do it when it's
forced perspective the set doesn't
conform to you know normal geometry and
so your film footage has to
adapt to that that's that's crazy you
know i thought i knew some cool vfx
about this movie but that was a new one
thank you yeah absolutely there are more
christmas movies that we haven't covered
so leave a comment down below which
other christmas movies we should take a
look at next year did you write to santa
hoping for longer react episodes well
guess what santa listened and partnered
with us to make it possible on
quarterdigital.com it's a christmas
dream come true
all you gotta do is open up your
stocking grab that little two week trial
out of it and sign up at
quarterdigital.com and get everything
that we put out including a 15 off all
of our merchandise access to all of our
exclusive shows like crew cuts son of a
dungeon functional filmmaking it's great
and the future is looking bright every
single day is black friday in this
household because 15 off is way blacker
than thursday
[Music]
well that was a lot of fun those were
very joyous movies joyous yes joyce
you know it's the end of the year it's
been a great year 2021 it's been super
super cool i hope you've enjoyed some of
these videos we've been putting out for
you the fact that we're able to do all
of these shows and you continue to enjoy
them is very special it means a lot to
me and i'm sure it means a lot to
everyone else here until next year have
a great holiday season happy new year
and we'll see you guys soon
you